what if marvel decided we didn't need
over 90 seconds of narcissistic
self-stimulation just to prove that
we're watching a marvel property and yes
we've send it every time and yes if
you're watching the season-long video
this might feel like you keep seeing it
over and over again and yes that's
exactly the point fine i've got the
shield you've got the sword more like
knives but cute wordplay not my black
widow would be terrible at cinemasins
because that's not cute wordplay that
was a forced and incorrect comparative
analysis cute wordplay would be if she
said fine i'll be your human shield but
you have no superpowers and are useless
addition to the team i mean i think
that's super cute nothing good has ever
followed the phrase bernard in
accounting nothing not bernard in
accounting just found a million dollar
tax write-off not bernard accounting has
identified the employee who's been
stealing from the company not bernard in
accounting was hanging out at a best buy
and just scored us all ps5s i thought
you were more than just a shield i'm a
pretty good dancer too non-funny
non-important non-sequiturs also
henchman has the drop on the protagonist
but instead of shooting them and
eliminating them immediately henchman
instead chooses to drop weapon and fight
hand to hand cliche are you seeing that
a valuable question considering that if
he did the watcher would be permanently
changing these timelines in fact we seem
to get confirmation that others do see
him in other universes and yet the show
will remain completely uninterested in
exploring these ideas when there's a
forced and unearned team-up plot to get
to dairy queen ah come on relax son
it'll all be over in a thousand years or
so this is the only scene that contains
one mr kurt vogel russell
stopping a living planet this easily
star-lord t'challa leader of the
ravagers and lost prince of wakanda you
have been chosen the watcher picking his
fantasy team reminds me of that first
big brother episode every season where
the players react being chosen to be in
the house so here's a sin for being
anything like a reality show and another
one for tricking me into admitting i
watch big brother gamora survivor of
sakaar and destroyer of thanos who did
what to who now and yeah somewhere this
character was from an episode that got
cut from the season for some reason and
that doesn't make this introduction any
less baffling or our investment in her
any list who gives a sh thing eric
stevens
killmonger tony stark's former protege
and killer
you
have been chosen killmonger killmonger
why pick the one most likely to destroy
your team and have some sort of ulterior
plan you know give me the nonsense they
try to sell later about the watcher
knowing the future possible futures or
whatever because that doesn't jive with
either his attitude or actions in other
parts of this series in this episode the
simple fact is that the watcher is
terrible at picking his team he drafts
worse than the cleveland cavs nobody
messes with vegas actually doesn't
everyone mess with vegas isn't that kind
of vegas's thing i will say it is nice
for getting some captain carter without
having to shoehorn steve rogers into it
some oh come on the pub facade was my
idea i read about it in your biography i
hope you like it i only want to make
peggy comfortable though the rest of you
or have a beer i don't give a sh yes
you may think thor is happy he's getting
a beer but he's actually exclaiming his
excitement that he managed to subtly
sneak in chekhov's plot convenient robot
head into this strange purgatorial pub
come on get a new trick man what was the
first trick did the watcher pull a bunny
out of his hat i always miss the good
stuff
you are
the guardians of the multiverse look i
know that's not the title of the show or
episode but that moment rolled
commercials so hard it's where they just
accidentally changed the title of the
show to guardians of the multiverse then
i would i wouldn't do that lady to be
fair thor probably wouldn't listen to
anything strange says but you'd still
think strange would try a little harder
than an i wouldn't do that considering
thor could very easily be walking to his
death we're in mind telling us what
we're up against and make sure you say
it loud enough and clear enough for the
audience who are probably mindlessly
scrolling through tiktok right now but
might need a little bit of this
exposition six stones of near
unfathomable power each controlling an
essential aspect of our existence
infinity stones you say do tell
also you have to love the stones on
marvel to be like hey we want to combine
our anthology series into a shared
narrative for the final episode how are
we feeling about a group of superheroes
teaming up to fight an evil power with
access to all six infinity stones this
is just like the school year i turned in
the exact same book report for every
book but just swapped out character
names and titles and just as lazy is
there a universe of chinese food that
has alternate dimension delivery tommy's
getting rumbly everyone said no thor
could be worse than end game thor and
what if said hold my ale the chandelier
survives this can i ask what happened
same thing that happened to you love is
love the code name of the super soldier
serum because what happened to captain
carter was the super soldier serum it's
a protection spell you're welcome and it
will protect you from the most powerful
being in the multiverse until the plot
needs it not to now we know doc's role
in the guardians of the multiverse is to
provide literal plot armor wait how is
ultra ultron using the stones outside of
his universe i thought we established
that was a no-go and loki and yes i'm
aware of the writers said something
about all the universes becoming like
one big soupy universe and that ultron
was a powered being via the stone so he
wasn't technically using them but that
sounds like some sort of wishing for
more wishes bullsh just admit you wanted
a cool multiversal battle so you broke
your own rules marvel usually you people
are much easier to kill yeah here's the
thing they are easy to kill you can
literally rewrite reality with one of
those stones so just snap them out of
existence and be done with it as yondu
says never doubt sticky fingers yep the
most cosmically powered being of all
time undone by pickpocketing god bless
you marvel god bless your little hearts
also oh no not the soul stone his only
remaining abilities are to control minds
time space power in the entire fabric of
reality also also those aren't fingers
that's your
what palm been hiding that the entire
time i know we've talked already about
how great thor would be at tv sins but
damn it i should have just let him write
the script i could have spent the day
catching up and i know what you did last
summer i i mean love island i mean um
look a cyclops
out of all the things that could help
stop ultron the best strange could come
up with is zombies
zombies even george a romero would tell
you that's a terrible [ __ ] idea there
are three people you trust in the
universe and i count myself lucky enough
to be one of them well
we must be close
i believe the term is bff and i believe
the term is bss someone drops in and the
only thing it takes to trust them is let
me make sure i have this right they tell
you to trust them i can destroy galaxies
with the thought ah then why don't you
destroy the guardians with a thought i'm
done pointing out all the stupid ways
ultron is not using his powers to end
this quickly like puny pew pewing the
dove injures instead of just manifesting
a thousand foot arm and grabbing the
stone but because the rest of this
episode is basically a somehow even
battle i'm adding 50 cents here so i can
rest easy tonight
[Music]
wait
what no clue man you're on your own
don't give him a shot yeah this is so
cool she's punching him and then she's
punching him and then she's
so now both of these time stones are
fighting each other in the same universe
beyond the breaking the rules part of
this if all stones could be used why
doesn't the watcher just go snag the
infinity stones from all other universes
and that way everyone can have their own
matching set i'm just saying there were
a lot of options that would probably
serve everyone better than this crew
trying to karate chop ultron to death
deus ex octina gotta love it when your
fancy restrainment spell depends on
actual manual force to maintain it hope
chris pratt doesn't show up it doesn't
feel over every single person's reaction
to the movie dune somehow makes it into
the episode of course the crusher was
designed to destroy the stones on my
world and your episode was designed to
be in this season of the show so that
any of this would make sense but we
can't always get what we want i guess
also if the crusher wasn't able to crush
those stones why did it give indicator
lights for each stone as if it was
accomplishing its goal is it in the
habit of claiming it's done amazing
things that it hasn't done stone crusher
should run for president
now isn't that convenient this one's for
you clinton black eye here shoots this
arrow before union jacked jumps from
approximately the same distance arrows
out of a compound boat can go upwards of
200 miles per hour and captain carter
wins that race by leaping from a
building's rooftop also cap lands on the
ground before hawk widow does which
somehow makes even less sense
considering she spent a few moments
playing piggyback with papatron also
also there are probably a good dozen
easier ways to get the ai into ultron
that don't involve an arrow but marvel
really wants us to believe hawkeye
served a purpose could someone explain
please i gave him a virus
a nasty one what if the ending of
independence day made sense nope no need
to explain this just hold the robot head
out and blammo all the suit and powers
just fly on over if anyone questions it
we'll just call it nanotransference or
something they'll buy it all next
question hydra never died it just
mutated that explains the stomach face
it does not someone needs to attend to
them if that pocket dimension cracks if
they escape i'll watch well thank
goodness steven is able to watch who
else possibly could have oversaw that
task it's not like watch is in any
character's name or anything wait
pulling a saint elsewhere you're not my
natasha
but something tells me you have her
spirit well that was wrapped up nicely
sweet mid-credit scene back in captain
carter's world this obviously means
she'll be getting her own show without
having to worry about steve rogers being
forced into everything she the hydra
stomper
yeah and there's someone inside damn it
that's a fugizi how do you know it's a
fugazi you looked at it for two seconds
[Music]
is he wearing a parachute no
no he wasn't
star-lord t'challa leader of the
ravagers and lost prince of wakanda you
have been chosen you choo-choo choose me
what is that
that is an overhead projector do you
ever use it anymore no not really yeah
is there a universe of chinese food that
has alternate dimension delivery tommy's
getting rumbly i'm so rumbly in my
cumbly i propose a toast true love is
hard to find
sometimes you think you have true love
and then you catch the early flight home
from
san diego and a couple of new people
jump out of your bathroom blindfolded
like a goddamn magic show ready to
double team your girlfriend
release the kraken